in this one guarded street you get a
pretty good idea of the argument that's
raging here
jewish settlers are trying to expel
palestinians from several homes in the
neighborhood
a move emblematic of the decades-long
conflict
this place shake gerard is the latest
flashpoint but it's the same old story
it's about territory in a shared holy
land it's about who lives where
in short it's a battle over whose ground
am i standing on
i went to meet muhammad al kird half his
family's house is now occupied by
settlers
the house that they've taken over we
live on the inside part he insists he's
not going anywhere
we will not leave reads the sign on his
fence
um what i see happening here is a
violent um displacement of palestinian
families
who are thrown out in their of their
homes and under international law that's
uh
that's a forcible transfer of population
which is a war crime
we took it in 1956. as we spoke his
father appeared with the document
signed by the jordanians in 1956
that he says proves their right to live
there
with no answer from the settlers
installed in the house
we went to the office in west jerusalem
of the man
leading attempts to settle jews in
sheikh gerard
making a real estate argument between
the arabs in sherach
to make it now a international uh fuss
it's something that is uh but for that
it's a real estate argument is it it's
an argument that goes to the very core
we talked about this video that emerged
in which a palestinian in-shape gerard
challenges a settler you are stealing
my house and if i don't steal it someone
else is going to steal it
one of your own settlers saying if i
don't steal it someone else will
acknowledge it you've had it you
you won't nobody said it but it's so
stupid you want me to
you want me to you you want you've had
the u.n you've had the u.n saying
what's happening could amount to a war
crime
what what could my war crime what
expelling
these people from their homes tell me
good amount
of war crimes under international so
i know what i'm praying for three times
at least every day
and i know what the muslims are reading
in the quran and i know what you are the
christian
reading in your old testimony and it's
written one thing
jerusalem is the land of israel
the land of the jewish people and there
you have the nub of it a snapshot of the
divisions of history
statehood and religion that run so very
deeply